what up Popo it's greg alba here this is
KCCI be I know Screen Rant I don't know
her from Screen Rant
but she's part of Screen Rant has
awesome videos on there and she is on
Instagram Twitter at hey underscore case
yes not see Kate like cold case case
like Casey like a murderer name it be
cold case killer gangster very obvious
old case killer
yeah I picked up on that hey we're gonna
watch from what culture today 10
terrible movies that ended an actor's
winning streak out of limits right yeah
Hollywood is a fickle business by its
nature box office jumping up and then
Johnny Depp the next business series of
eveness some of those for the services
without the sense rather claim I'm out
of inappropriate comedy with 10 terrible
movies that killed an actor's winning
strangers compute number 10 wild wild
west
Will Smith Will Smith got off to a hot
run early as the rib beginning with six
degrees of separation is critical
success Pollock like bad boys
independence they men in black I like
that movie I have to
a budget with great lovely panic for the
effects first and coasting on Smith's
presents rather than fashioning a fun
script about routine and or Tooting no
man I the box Cameron Diaz yes I want a
hell of a sweet start me mm we've all
been in that situation
right I mean damn some others but she
proved it yet sighs for pulling power
with all his history three Richard
Kenny's third feature the box another
disappointment Donnie Darko director
adapting which man hello Johnny February
with an intriguing buildup of fades
liver improving pale
it received just 33 million dollar box
office a 30 million dollar budget barely
breaking even
I'm an aged snake oh I've seen this
movie snake eyes yes
never forget that he's an oscar-winning
Nicolas Cage yeah hold it was 14 second
box office magic attack you fix the rock
comment face office was romantic drama
City of Angels the film that broke the
street Brian De Palma strangely tedious
conspiracy thriller snake eyes plenty
directing it grossing nearly impossible
a million dollars tiny number six
one hell of a friendly hot streak in the
1980 Rockies two and three nine horse
escape to victory and post round both
first luck don't approach me yeah
limestone a hilariously mr. de jambe
Paris alone with Dolly Parton and
netting the act of his first of many
ratty wins for worst actor there was a
certain quality to it in retrospect yeah
dude 1 million of its 28 million dollar
budget
hi one for the money you have a sharika
poster oh I like this movie oh that's my
boy I love it it's kind of funny Jill
broke the street now explain why so many
people saw Jack and Jill
but wouldn't throw down some cash that
that's my boy except perhaps audiences
if eating cats are rated number three
the distinguished gentleman Eddie right
at the gate we had an untouchable
running movie sequel the golden child
stand-up comedy film Eddie Murphy roar
Raging Bull true confessions the king of
comedy in love Raziel the mission angel
are the untouchables Midnight Run and
Jack you've moved in bed too - well
commercially there at least well
reviewed at the time and a number of
them as classic broke that streak
because if I may be the first into the
actors to decline the David Mamet
written we're No Angels and Sean Penn in
I like his voice it makes it nice it's
like Jarvis
have you seen wild wild west yes are you
sure I don't remember it very well
well a fantastic song why don't we go
wah wah Wes Wes desperado Rough Rider no
you don't know nada I don't know what he
says here none of this Six Gun and his
brother running this Buffalo Soldier
look it's like I told you
anyway okay so the movie yeah this is
like considered a really hated movie and
every time I watch it
I'd laugh I didn't ever hear that it was
bad we have a two year difference I know
everything about every movie nothing
about Wes Wow Wes was like considered a
failure at the box office and logically
Pam is from the same guy I made men in
black but men in black was like great
man in black was great
there's a pivotal point in Will Smith's
career because he was like wow I really
saw after the reception a while less
there had been more careful with how I
choose my movies huh and every time I
watch that movie I'm like if someone
were to ask me what is one movie you
love or like that everyone hates I would
say wah wah West this will get our video
demonetised but I have to mention it in
the beginning Will Smith is making love
with a woman who you never see again in
the movie and then when the water thing
therein falls over there's a shot where
he stands up you could totally see his
testicles whoa I'm telling you slowed
down I showed it a couple weeks ago my
best friend on Netflix it's on Netflix
go find dad sadly yeah you could see his
testicles ro and he stands up and it's
brief in the movies pg-13 no one cares
everyone stop watching by now it's all
about the director Cameron Diaz I did I
forgot how many hits this woman's had I
didn't this is also where I was living
while you were really she's made a lot
of movies man yeah leave it okay yes no
sky sweetest thing what I was missing
gangs in New York yeah one that's every
teen girls favorite movie all right I
know you know Daniels for sure
full throttle Shrek right action track I
haven't heard him in her shoes I saw
that I can't tell you a thing about it
but I saw it the holidays are great
that's one of my favorite movies without
the Vegas that's a movie I stand by that
is probably terrible
like retrospectively it's probably a
terrible movie I love that movie really
mr. justice keeper also a great movie
really sad about cancer uh yeah what
cancer is never funny it's not sure that
that's true should do that the movie the
box this director so fascinating to me
who made it because he made Donnie Darko
which is this a monumental like cult hit
did you like Donnie Darko I like it when
I'm on YouTube when I'm not on YouTube
I'm like I don't really get what the
hell's going on I hung out with that
director once uh-huh connected I'm so
connected that's why you should we
should get coffee talk business he's an
interesting fella I don't know if you'd
remember me but we like hung out the
gates were like we were like yeah thanks
I said to him so I'm sure you get this
all the time right what's the most
annoying question you get yes why and
then he said yeah what's it about
that's like the most commonly used
question but I feel like it's annoying
because you're like uh I didn't just
spend my entire yeah for people not to
get it you know and this we were a group
of people and when we were hanging out
that's just a few of us he was on
Twitter the entire time what did I think
that's how he made the box uh he just
wasn't focused oh you're just distracted
by social media you got a focus man
whose name I forgot who I hung out with
for five hours I'm sure he appreciates
your geometry on his on his personal
life yeah yeah I was ignoring him so I
went on Twitter of it as me stupid
question
couldn't leave my friends weren't taken
get out it was an annoying thing you
might think about that it uh yeah you
know I should look different his
perspective
yeah whatever his name was Nicholas Cage
this movie Snake Eyes I'm sure this is a
fascinating topic for you because you
you have no idea what the movie Brian De
Palma who directed it is he did like
Untouchables in Scarface and Nicolas
Cage wasn't the Nicolas Cage we have now
and I saw so now I was young right it
was so cool to watch yeah and then I got
older and realized this ain't a good
movie yeah well you know what a feeling
I don't have that with what Wilde why
that movie stands the test of time
people Jennifer Aniston yeah that woman
who will I think will always be hot oh
wait that's her that's her today I don't
understand it how old she yes it's yoga
man I was about to say that [ __ ] me
but I didn't wonder bring I didn't want
to bring the vibes in because then we go
on to tangent like oh that's all you've
opened the door to promote like
spiritual health hey man it's a great
thing Madonna says yoga is the thing
that keeps your looking good
and yeah Anderson said the same thing I
think because all these celebs do yoga a
lot of people have latched on to yoga
Oprah says secrets a good book suddenly
everyone wants to know about Law of
Attraction famous people well
influential people yeah yeah Amos people
if you're famous I listen to you Kanye
West is right about everything
I mean I haven't even heard of this film
management which is amazing because I
love Jennifer Aniston yep friends one of
my all-time favorite shows of all time
these fantastic actors and I like Steve
Zahn though I think it's a great actor
and the kind of like brother and sister
there may be a lovers they look like
similar they look like when you see a
dude who is okay looking and then you
find out he has a hot sister oh yeah
that's exactly
yeah same color that is it yeah yeah
this is the commentary you were hoping
for today it's really like it's really
deep and insightful intellectual yeah
you know we provide like more
behind-the-scenes knowledge what's going
on okay that's my boy I gotta defend
this movie to you guys all right
have you seen that's my boy I'm sure I
have we not like Adam Sandler
not in particularly yeah no one really
does
I appreciate the hustle yeah to show up
on set to make things that are he just
keeps going and people keep watching I
don't know why it for you I can't go for
it dude I mean really he's a really nice
person too silly great that's it he puts
out love and he gets he gets stuff in
return I think he's a great dramatic
actor actually really I think he's a
fantastic movie did you see that would
inform that opinion punch-drunk love oh
okay punch-drunk love he did that one
movie about the guy who was who lost his
family in 9/11 and his reign over me a
reign on me
funny people I think he does a really
good job of that too I think it's a
great reminder but that's my boy why I
really like that movie I felt like funny
people and that's my boy came out kind
of close to each other and I feel like
he was trying to transition his career a
little bit to do more edgy material but
both those movies bombed at the box
office and the thing is he tends to do
like these crude raunchy pg-13 comedies
right that are kind of lazy and then he
does funny people and that's my boy
which I felt put in more effort and were
more edgy material and they earned their
are ratings
people like what is this I can't take my
kids to watch these part jokes yeah
makes sense now
and then I felt like he just started
going back to like dumb pg-13 comedies
gotta I think that's my boy was
hilarious the first 20 nights are
annoying but I think that
it's really fun sorry I have a sound I
wish you had a better career you seem
unhappy yeah
she does seem unhappy and let you blow
him all the way to the bank I was asking
you before we filmed like what were some
of your fare movies you said meaning
girls you said your favorite actors of
all time is Lindsay Lowe yes I say that
yeah you said your number-one
inspiration Lindsay Lohan come on you're
taking improv yes answer yes and this
[ __ ] Mean Girls yes because it's
Tina Fey and rack on that Addams yeah
yeah it's so funny how Rachel McAdams
has the most blossoming career out of
any girl I know she's very good in this
movie she's fantastic and you know she
never plays that kind of character but
she's a great Queen she's not she plays
this role like how Meryl Streep played
so how she played The Devil Wears Prada
they played against the nastiness yeah
she's just really real and in their
leaves it layers you can see that
there's something underneath to whatever
is being put out on the surface and it's
really easy to play it like yeah
where'd you get a bracelet you put the
black she's like where did you get that
bracelet and people saw she's pretty
nude I'm really actually manipulating
you right now that's right that's what I
base my manipulation her way I haven't
heard of this De Niro movie whatever De
Niro is always like freaking weird these
days he's weird now he did silver
linings playbook he also did dirty
grandpa that's true here right thanks
yes well guys subscribe to what culture
they're a great Channel I'm Greg this is
the real rejects you can subscribe here
click that notification about if you
like patreon it's a good site check it
out become a patron ejecta that Casey
Spivey you have a middle name is that
public yeah I'm sure it is
Lane keator Lane que cela sounds like a
like a comic book
heroine Kate Lane
I almost went by Casey Lane Louis like I
know that's what I was thinking I wasn't
thinking about yeah but Casey Spivey
kind of looks like Kevin Spacey so like
that's probably a good thing looks like
that you know jeez hey underscore case
on Instagram and Twitter follow her I
sure do
how often do you put up videos on screen
right Oh twice a day twice a day
yeah every day six days Wow Sunday's
aah-ha-ha-ha hustle aah laughter go
check it out she writes the stories
herself